[Music]
jlo
almost made it instagram official with
ben posting this throwback to what she
called
her favorite album this is me then
celebrating the surprising fact that
it's back on the charts
oh but we see you jlo
[Music]
the 2002 album was dedicated to ben
featured him in one of the videos and he
inspired the title he was like you know
this is
your music and it's great and it's who
you are there's even a song called
dear ben i'm
[Music]
and to addicted it all off ben used one
song off the album to set the scene for
his 2002
proposal so many candles and
buzzes with bouquets and and my song
glad was playing
get the message well there's more just
one hour before jlo's post
a-rod shared a photo that also had
people wondering about a hidden meeting
the pic shows alex having dinner with
his daughters but look
there are three empty table settings
which in theory
could be for jlo and her two kids max
and emmy
a source tells e.t a-rod was surprised
by how quickly jennifer lopez reunited
with ben affleck after their breakup but
you know who's not mad
j law jennifer lopez and ben affleck are
back
together jennifer lawrence was on a
friend's podcast and
freaked out when she heard the benefit
news they are
on vacation with each other right now
i'm so excited
i'm so happy for them